from
green and glitzy to a well-loved hoodie
you gotta look back at audrey hepburn
for an uh
funny face she also wore a hoodie um
no that's not true the stars brought
their fashion a game to the 78th annual
golden globes on sunday night although
it was a completely virtual affair
due to the kovid 19 crisis celebrities
still dressed to impress showing off
some major fashion moments while
celebrating the year's
best in tv and film oh i'm desperate for
a christian moment
i'll give it to you i promise amanda
seifried
promised e.t a fashion moment and
she delivered in her custom strapless
coral oscar de la renta dress which
featured
hand-crafted taffeta silk flowers
singer turned actress andra day stunned
in a custom gorgeous gray chanel gown
with her hair pulled back as she
accepted her award
for best actress in a motion picture
drama for her portrayal of the iconic
billie holiday
in the united states versus billie
holiday
from home to all the incredible nominees
i can't believe i'm in the presence of
giants
shades of green were on theme during a
sunday show
as cynthia arrivo was daring in this
structured
neon valentino couture dress as she
attended the actual event
to present cynthia's futuristic look
styled by jason bolden was accessorized
with metallic
silver platform wedges ivory opera
length
leather gloves and purple eyeliner
leslie odom jr also donned a pop of neon
underneath his maison valentino suit
while dan levy was chic in chartreuse
wowing in this valentino getup for the
award show
complete with a matching sequin
turtleneck
platform metallic shoes and his
signature
spectacles
the queen's gambit star anya taylor joy
was the queen of old hollywood glamour
as she stepped out in a sparkling
emerald dior
oate couture gown with a plunging
neckline
and a matching floor-length coat
with the help of her stylist la roach
anya looked
fabulous in over one million dollars
worth of tiffany and code diamonds
i don't think my body understands what's
going on intellectually i kind of do but
my body's going to take a bit of time
but i'm happy
i'm really happy spike lee's sun and
golden globe ambassador
jackson lee wore a green kimono inspired
custom gucci coat he paired with a black
suit
and matching bolo tie and a time's up
pin congratulations catherine o'hara you
are a queen
and icon and i will happily lose to you
any single day
while kaylee cuoco didn't take home the
golden globe for best actress in a
musical or comedy series
for her role in flight attendant she won
us
over when it came to her sparkling
fashion
and her sister brie cuoco couldn't help
but get emotional when first
seeing her over-the-top look
kaylie's stylist brad goreski teased her
sparkling oscar de la renta number
ahead of the show living it during this
time right now
and and also being very um conscious of
what is going on
in the world um but then also on the
flip side of that
too you know having a little bit of fun
right now and bringing a little bit of
glitz and sparkle you know back into the
world
tiffany haddish was glamorous in her
custom brown and silver embellished
alberta ferretti gown
as she was there presenting the award
for best animated motion picture
tiffany paired the look with statement
earrings a metallic clutch
and her cropped blonde hairdo as the
award show
was a mostly virtual event a laid back
style was to be expected
and there were definitely a few more
subdued looks of the night with margot
robbie's off-the-shoulder metallic and
black chanel frock
and chain-link purse
to jodie foster's prada pajamas
and there was jason tzedekis's cozy
ensemble
the actor accepted his award for best
actor in a comedy series
for his role in ted lasso rocking a neon
green
and blue tie-dye hoodie while at home
that feels like home to me that makes me
feel very at home
also if anybody wants to know where they
can get jason sedakis's hoodie go to
nbc.com
backslash globes fashion
[Applause]
[Music]